welcome to Nairobi National Park the
only National Park in the world the
directly borders a city if you're lucky
you'll spot wildebeest giraffes and even
the ever elusive pride of lions but
looking at the land from the air you'll
notice a different kind of creature the
standard gauge railway authorities say
out of seven possible routes this was
the best option what we established was
at all those other possible possible
routes one were going to have a lot more
impact on the park because we are going
to acquire more land from the National
Park in excess of 100 hundred and fifty
acres but what the option that we took
was the option of building a bridge
across the national we are building a
bridge wonder Anita two pyres for a
bridge of 5.8 kilometers the amount of
land that bridge will take on the
National Park is 0.1 0.5 1 of an acre
that is half an acre of land but
environmentalists accused the Kenyan
government of not following due process
before construction began well it's
really a sequence of very unfortunate
events starting off really with the the
very poorly planned and executed plans
for the narrow standard gauge railway to
Kenya at the current at the moment
really the railway is being built
through the Nairobi National Park in
contravention of court orders stopping
it and the reasons why campaigns such as
ourselves and other concerned
individuals went to court to stop it was
because we feel the right sort of
planning was not
considered or executed when thinking
about this project it floated very many
laws in Kenya particularly environmental
laws while the Train will offer
passengers a view of a lifetime while
passing through the national park
conservationists are concerned that this
construction will affect the ecosystem
and the wildlife that live here short
time surely there would be an impact
also because we've seen that they've
been blasting in the park to prove you
know to put the foundation for the
pillars for the railway etc so yes the
temporary barriers the blasting the
noise the movement of all have impact on
the wildlife in the park but again none
of that has been studied previously none
of it has been catered for in any
mitigation measures the project has been
a controversial topic in Kenya even
before construction four years ago the
first phase which runs from Kenya's
coastal city of Mombasa to Nairobi has
already been completed the second phase
is what you see here at nearly 5 million
euros a kilometre construction has cost
the country 2.8 billion euros in loans
from the Chinese government reports
suggest that more than eight million
euros has been lost in dubious land
compensation deals and with a railway
running through a National Heritage Site
many Kenyans are concerned the country
isn't getting value for money the
government says it will rehabilitate the
land once construction is finished but
for wildlife populations it may already
be too late
[Music]